all right welcome back so I see that a
scared a few people off which is good
because so now the things are gonna get
technical so but X be a Banach space all
right so there are lots of matrix
concentration and equalities so you can
do Bernstein with unbounded random
matrices for example there are matrix
Series bounds which we'll talk about in
a minute
there are matrix cheran off bounds
there are matrix azuma bounds anyway
basically take every one of your
favorite concentration inequalities and
put matrix in front and there might be a
version so all these things you do in
the scalar setting can be transported to
the matrix setting by sticking matrix in
front usually with a much harder proof
and so this really is a pretty extensive
toolbox so what we're going to do the
next two hours is talk about two methods
that can be used to establish these
types of results normally like I said in
these tutorials what I would do is
repeat what I just did five more times
here's a matrix you can write it as an
independent sum here's a concentration
inequality that you comply to that sum
here's what happens when you compute the
variance so you know we'll watch this so
but it's in the notes if you're
interested in these examples so what
we're going to do first is I'm going to
show you how to prove a tail bound for
matrix Rademacher series I'll tell you
what that is in case it's not clear and
the method of proof is the Laplace
transform
method which is the simplest way to
prove scalar concentration inequalities
plus a very deep result for matrix
analysis called leaves theorem so that's
going to be the topic of this lecture so
I'm going to show you one of the
successful methods for proving matrix
concentration results and then in the
third lecture for those of you who
survive we're going to prove a moment
bound or a matrix Rademacher series and
the approach here so this is called the
non commutative Kinchin inequality or
the matrix congenita quality some of you
may have heard heard of this before
we're gonna prove this using steins
method so a very very different kind of
technique and this is the simplest proof
I know for this result it's extremely
powerful and even in the scalar setting
these results are not necessarily so
easy to prove so this is a really slick
way to get a lot of juice ok so here's
what we're gonna be doing I'm gonna
start with the scalar case just to
remind you how this stuff goes and then
I'll show you how to extend the matrix
setting so most of the work in this
lecture is from a paper I wrote called
user-friendly tail bounds that appeared
in fo CM in 2012 foundation of the
computational math okay so all of the
stuff that I'm telling you about is
based on a principle that I think we can
safely attribute to all's Vetta and
winter and that principle comes from a
paper about something that doesn't seem
like it as much to do with random
matrices so all's been in winter
information theorists and they're
interested in the capacity of quantum
channels and to analyze these things
they had recourse to study a certain
kind of random
and so somewhere buried in the back of
their paper they're like we thought
these tools might have some additional
application or use so we thought we
would you know write all of this stuff
out and in the back of the paper they
prove a very simple version of the
matrix chair Knopf and equality and what
I really think is powerful about their
paper is not so much the particulars of
their proof but the idea that we can
prove matrix concentration inequalities
by lifting scaler concentration
inequalities and in fact we can lift the
arguments and to make this work you need
a lot more machinery you'll see part of
the reason why this is true but this has
actually been a very successful
principle and both of the results I'm
going to tell you about follow from the
same template and this is really an idea
that I think we can attribute to these
guys because this is exactly what they
did in their paper okay so what is a
Rademacher series this is an object form
you'll be studying for the rest of the
afternoon so a scaler Rademacher series
has two pieces so we need some
coefficients so we're gonna let a 1 up
to n the real numbers these are fixed
and we need some randomness because
we're talking about probability so we'll
let epsilon 1 up to epsilon n be iid
Rademacher variables which is to say
uniform on plus/minus 1 so we often call
these guys Rademacher random variables
and I'm gonna follow that convention so
independent identically distributed
random signs and we're interested in the
random matrix
X
which is given by modulating these
scalar coefficients by random signs and
adding them up okay so might be
interested in the tail behavior of this
kind of random variable so what's the
probability that X exceeds some level T
so I'll prove this result for you in a
minute but it's pretty well known that
this type of random variable has a tail
bound of this form it looks like a
Gaussian and the variance it's just the
expectation of x squared which you can
easily compute as the l2 norm of the
sequence of coefficients okay so the l2
norm of the sequence of coefficients is
in fact the variance of this random
variable and it controls the moderate
and large deviations of this random
variable increment serum will tell you
that in fact this estimate is more or
less sharp asymptotically okay so this
is a good bound and it says that this
random variable looks like a Gaussian so
centered around zero and the width of
the lobe is roughly zero roughly Sigma
direction okay
now what's the matrix Rademacher series
so it's a simple extension but instead
of scalar coefficients we're gonna have
some matrix coefficients so we're gonna
let a 1 up to a n be D by D hermitian
matrices
okay so her Mitchum means conjugates
symmetric if you prefer just think
symmetric now the thing about a
hermitian matrix is you may learn in an
operator theory classes it's really the
matrix equivalent of a real number okay
so just like a real number is equal to
its conjugate a hermitian matrix is
equal to its conjugate transpose and
relational matrices actually behave a
lot like real numbers which is maybe a
little bit surprising but with the right
tools from operator theory you can
really a push through this inside okay
so once again we're gonna need some
randomness so we'll let epsilon 1 up to
epsilon n be iid Rademacher z-- so these
are scalars still and we are going to
make a random matrix X by modulating
these matrix coefficients by these
random variables and adding them up so
flip the sign of each matrix add them up
see what happens okay
so we'd like to understand how big X is
we'd like to know the probability that
it exceeds some level and we'd like
something here on the right now there's
a problem what it would have big mean
when we're talking about a matrix so
we're gonna measure the size in terms of
the maximum eigen value so the algebraic
largest eigen value would like to know
the probability that it see it's some
level T we'd like to fill this in and
know the AI are not random yeah the mean
come from the Epsilon's okay so we'd
like to fill in this blank here and what
I'm gonna argue is that the method we
used to prove this result has a direct
extension that'll lets us prove a result
of this form for the moment I'm going to
leave you in suspense about what belongs
in the blank
so let me remind you about how you prove
that sub Gaussian bound for a Rademacher
series in the scalar case I'm going to
go through this quickly because I expect
most of you have seen this at some point
in your lives or taught this at some
point in your lives so okay so the first
thing we're gonna do is apply what's
called the Laplace transform method so
this is often known as chairing off
bounding or hoof ting bounding really it
goes back to Bernstein in the 1920s
I've been chastised for saying that but
there really is a very old technique
from from the Russian literature so
we're going to be interested in the
probability that this Rademacher series
and the scalar case exceeds a level T
and the way that we're going to deal
with this is by fixing a scalar
parameter theta which is non-negative
sorry it's strictly positive we're gonna
multiply both sides of this event by
theta doesn't change the event and then
we're gonna exponentiate the exponential
monotone so it doesn't change the event
so this is equal to the probability that
the exponential of theta times epsilon k
a k is greater than e to the theta t
it's the same event same probability all
right now we're going to apply Markov's
inequality to this non-negative random
variable so Markov inequality tells us
that the probability is bounded by the
reciprocal of the level so e to the
minus theta T times the expectation of
the random variable
okay so that's step one this is um the
integral of an exponential with a
parameter in it which is the reason for
the name will cost transform okay now we
need to stare at this thing okay so
what's this object called this is called
a moment generating function of the some
X now X is the sum of independent
variables and what we're going to need
to show is that the moment generating
function of the sum is the product of mg
F's so the second step is to show that
the MGF of a sum of an independent sum
equals the product of the MGF of the sum
ends so this is really easy because of
independent can't keep track of these
erasers
all right so what do we do so the
expectation of the sum of independent
variables
well the exponential the sum is always
equal to the product of the
Exponential's and by independence we can
swap the product in the expectation and
what we have here now is the MGF of each
sum and okay so we have an MGF of the
sum and we have an MGF of the sum is so
now if we want to continue we need to
bound this moment generating function
okay so let's have a look at this guy so
this is a Rademacher times a parameter
theta times a number a so Rademacher
takes two different values plus one
minus one with equal probability so this
is equal to one-half times e to the plus
theta a plus one half times e to the
minus theta a of corresponding the two
values of epsilon so this look familiar
this has got a name it's the hyperbolic
cosine of theta a and I'm cleverly going
to bound this by the exponential of
theta squared over two times a squared
so to know that this is the right bound
it helps to fiddle around for a while
okay
so we've found it each one of the MGF we
can introduce this back in here
and we'll obtain so now we can complete
the argument so the probability that the
sum is greater than T is less than or
equal to e to the minus theta T times
the product of e to the theta squared
over two times a K squared so we plug
this bound into here plug that into
there and now we pull the product back
into the Exponential's we obtain e to
the minus theta T times the exponential
of theta squared over two times the sum
of a K squared and this is the number
that we were calling Sigma squared
before the variance of the sum
and now what's the last step
so theta is at our disposal so we can
optimize with respect to theta and when
we do that we'll obtain the probability
of the Rademacher series exceeding the
level T is less than or equal to e to
the minus T squared over 2 Sigma squared
where Sigma squared is equal to the sum
of a K squared okay so yes this is an
identity this is a bound and you can get
this by comparing Taylor series yeah so
you can check for the first derivatives
match is zero yeah it's really just a
clever choice to make this work out
neatly you can actually finish the proof
with the hyperbolic cosine and you get
an even better bound but it's hard to
understand so this one makes it very
clear that this ought to have this
Gaussian so Piazzi behavior okay so this
is just a reminder of how we do things
in the scalar case and now I'm going to
try and do the same thing for matrices
okay so here's our set up now X is a
random matrix we're interested in
filling in this blank here and we're
gonna try and do that by following the
same steps on the far side of the board
so
so it's a race what needs to be erased I
am but it's enough to rewrite the whole
thing so proof by capitalization okay so
the probability that the maximum eigen
value of this random matrix X exceeds T
well
let's multiply both sides by theta and
exponentiate just like we did a minute
ago the probability that e to the theta
lambda max X is greater than e to the
theta T is exactly the same event so
probability is the same now we're going
to apply markov inequality and we
reciprocate the level and we have the
expectation of e to the theta lambda max
of X and this is exactly what we did
before now we're gonna do something else
okay I don't like this maximum eigen
value because it's hard to deal with
so the first thing I'm going to do is
draw the maximum eigen value out of the
exponential so you can certainly move
theta inside because it's a positive
number and the maximum eigen value is
positive homogeneous and the spectral
mapping theorem tells us that the
expectation sorry the exponential of the
maximum eigen value is equal to the
maximum eigen value of the exponential
okay so this is equal to e to the minus
theta T times maximum eigen value of e
to the theta times X and this is defined
for example by a power series just like
you do in your differential equations
class and if you want to get fancy
you're right
spectral mapping theorem in the margin
now we're gonna do one more thing that
seems kind of counterintuitive because
it seems like a terrible thing to do the
exponential of a hermitian matrix is
positive because it takes all of the
eigenvalues and makes them positive
numbers this is a positive definite
matrix the maximum eigenvalue of a
positive definite matrix is dominated by
the trace so the sum of the eigenvalues
so we're gonna make this change to get
rid of the maximum eigen value entirely
because like I said I really don't like
this Mike some eigenvalue it's kind of a
nightmare to deal with okay now it seems
like this is a terrible estimate you can
also start to see where that dimensional
factor is coming from in these matrix
bounds it turns out you're not actually
losing very much here and what you gain
is access to the miraculous properties
of the trace or more precisely the trace
exponential okay
so just carry this eraser around okay
now we'd like to continue our
calculation by converting the moment
generating function of the sum into the
product of the moment generating
functions but now we're in trouble oh I
should also add before I forget that in
the matrix setting this argument is due
to Olivera he was the one who identified
that you can use the spectral mapping
theorem and apply this direct argument
here yep
well no no you're not because no no
because you can't pass the trace through
the exponential you got to determine it
when you do that so yeah you need to do
it in this order yeah you got to do it
in this order and that's why the loss is
so small yes the best
requires some argument but like I said
if you want to get fancy okay
I'm just showing off yeah so now we'd
really like to argue that the MGF of a
sum is equal to the product of MGS and
now we're in trouble
okay so let's see what happens here so
in the scalar case the first thing we
did we use the fact that that the
exponential of a sum is equal to the
exponential of a product is this true
for matrices epic failure in fact this
is never true for symmetric matrices
unless they commute okay so this could
not be farther from the truth
all right now it turns out that there
was a limited substitute so if you stick
a trace in front you were dumped race
here right so I mean it's not like we
really need the raw Exponential's here
so how does this compare with the
trace of e to the a times e to the B
well it turns out that this is larger
than this always and this is a result
from statistical physics called the
golden Thompson and equality dates back
to around 1965 and this is the approach
that alls veteran and winter used to
continue the argument but there's a
difficulty here which is that we
actually have a sum of a bunch of
matrices and we'd like to compare that
in some sense with the Exponential's of
the individual sum ends is there any
relation between these two quantities
obviously having the answer is no okay
so you stare with this for a minute and
there's an example involving a poly spin
matrices or something like that you show
that this is not true in general but
when you stare at this for a minute it
starts to become clear why this is the
wrong way to think about this problem so
if you multiply three positive definite
matrices together as a result symmetric
so no not symmetric even let alone
positive I mean the trace could be
complex I mean you could try and fix
that by putting on an absolute value or
something like that but you see the
trouble is that multiplying matrices
together destroys the spectral
properties of the product I mean so it
doesn't the product doesn't really
inherit all that much from the
individual guys and that's why you run
into trouble here so we need to do
something else so so all's veteran
winter use this approach in a very
clever way to finish the proof well the
very use this in an even more clever way
to establish his results I'm going to do
something different so at this point you
scratch your head and you go to the
library for two or three months and
eventually you merge coughing from the
dust and you realize that maybe you
shouldn't be working with the
moment-generating function we're gonna
use the cumulant generating function
okay so what's a cumulative it's just
the log of the moment-generating
function
and the interesting thing is that in the
scaler setting if you take the log of
the moment generating function of an
independent sum this is equal to the sum
of the logarithms of the moment
generating functions of the some ads
over Chaput data's in here so the in the
scalar case just by taking the logarithm
of the calculation we made before we see
that the cumulant generating function of
an independent sum is the sum of the
cumulant generating functions so cg f of
independent some sum of c GF s-- alright
now this looks more promising for
matrices doesn't it because what happens
when you add symmetric matrices together
oh there's still symmetric alright and
this is what we're gonna take advantage
of this is not true by the way in the
matrix case so you have to do more work
so this is a what's going on in the
library for all of those months trying
to figure out what you're gonna do
instead and eventually
you come across a another result so
here's what we're gonna do so in 1973
Eliot leave was studying the problem of
the stability of matter so why it is a
lots of um quantum systems have nice
bulk behavior and along the way to this
he proved the following theorem so what
h b-- permission then the map from a to
the trace exponential of h plus log a is
con cave on the positive definite cone
so this takes a positive definite matrix
a and spits out a number and on the
collection of positive definite matrices
this function is concave obviously so
what happens if this is a scaler well
this is just a times the exponential of
age it's a linear na alright so there's
something new happening with matrices
that wasn't happening with scalars and
leap of the the deep inside to
understand that this was the case and to
establish this theorem so what does this
have to do with our problem well it
turns out this was all his probabilistic
content and that was the insight that my
hat after all of those months in the
library so we're gonna let H be a fixed
hermitian matrix and we're gonna let X
be random hermitian and what we're
interested in doing is computing things
that look like the expectation of the
trace of e to the h plus X because you
know we've got a sum of a whole bunch of
random matrices here and so we'd like to
break that something down
sir so X is a yeah any distribution over
the hermitian matrices whatsoever so it
turns out that this is less than the
trace of the exponential of h plus log
expectation of e to the ax alright why
is that one word one word Jenson all
right so all we did here is we wrote X
as log of e to the X and we applied
Jensen's inequality that's it but now
what do we have here
what's our friend the cumulant
generating function aha okay I'm any
questions on what we've just done here
this is a technical kernel of this proof
we write x equals log e to the X and
then using Jensen's inequality we've
pulled the expectation inside the
concave function that's all this is
really like a one-line argument in one
of the papers I wrote this out and the
referee chastised me for including the
details
we defined the log of of the trees so
for example you can diagonalize it and
take the log of each eigenvalue if it's
positive definite yeah well you may be a
better way for our purposes is the
functional inverse of the exponential
okay any other questions on this sir
this is a stronger result I think
have to think about the here you're
taking the average of many weaknesses
right excess can take many values many
well I mean they are related I mean you
can use similar ideas to prove a version
of the golden town a strengthened
version of the golden Thompson
inequality but somehow like if you want
to think about this probabilistically
you really want to think about cumulant
generating functions here somehow there
so the right conceptual framework for
this and so by iterating this approach
yeah the Baker Campbell house store for
identity yeah so what happens is there's
another term involving commutator z' and
then the series will continue I haven't
seen any applications of that idea
although it seems plausible that yeah
that you could push that through it is
just that the identities are very
complicated and they were people usually
don't even write them out and beyond the
second term yeah I do
can we talk about that a little later
it's the entropy of e to the a yes
that's how you prove this I'll tell you
more later if you'd like all right um
any other questions on this okay what
are we gonna do we're gonna iterate this
argument so now if you've got the trace
of e to the sum of say theta epsilon k a
k by repeatedly applying this result we
will obtain the trace exponential of the
sum of the logarithm of the expectation
of e to the theta epsilon k a k alright
so all we did was peel the terms off the
sum one at a time using this result and
we use independence to note that with
respect to the randomness in each sum
and the rest of the terms are fixed okay
so we used independence in a very strong
way here okay so we computed this
expectation as an iterated expectation
peeling the terms off one at a time and
we used independence to do that so plays
a big role here but this is the matrix
extension of that result okay so this is
the matrix cgf of a sum and this is the
sum of matrix c g FS
all right so the next step and the
argument is to figure out what these
CDF's look like so step three CGF pounds
so let's have a look so we've got a
fixed matrix a a number theta and a
Rademacher variable so let's compute the
expectation well this takes values plus
minus one we just with equal probability
so we get 1/2 e to the theta a plus 1/2
e to the minus theta a this is also
known as the hyperbolic cosine of theta
ade and by diagonalizing this matrix we
obtain an upper bound of e to the theta
squared over two times a in the semi
definite order same inequalities before
applied to the eigenvalues and this is a
semi definite inequality alright now we
can take logarithms of both sides you're
absolutely right I'm really really bad
at arithmetic ok so I'm also really bad
at keeping track of the top of this
marker okay so we take the logarithm and
we wind up with this semi definite bound
for the CGL by the way you need some
machinery to do this so the log is
operator monotone so this so you
understand that this is a requires some
attention okay
now we've got a bound for the cgf it
turns out the trace exponential is also
monotone with respect to the semi
definite order and so we can complete
this bound by plugging in these
estimates here so we get the trace
exponential of the sum of a K squared
now you can see this thing here this
matrix as the expectation of X this
random matrix formed by summing up the a
K with Rademacher variables so this is
the expectation of x squared like a
variance but now it's a matrix and not a
scalar okay so to finish the proof we're
going to take this estimate and plug it
in to this calculation here
so continuing we have e to the minus
theta T times the trace exponential of
theta squared over two times expectation
of x squared now we don't like this
trace anymore we want to get back to
some eigen values so we're gonna bound
the trace by the maximum eigen value
times the dimension
sir T is the level yeah I'll be
continuing this calculation not that one
okay so we've just taken this estimate
here and we've introduced it into the
last line of the Laplace transform
result okay so now we're finishing up so
this is dominated by e to the minus
theta T times D times lambda max of the
exponential of theta squared over 2 all
right now we're gonna apply the spectral
mapping theorem in Reverse so we're
going to pull the maximum eigen value
inside the exponential inside the theta
squared over 2 until it lands on this
all right now we're gonna call this guy
Sigma squared it's just sort of the
variance of the random matrix and we're
gonna minimize over theta greater than
zero and will obtain the bound D at
times the exponential of minus T squared
over 2 Sigma squared where Sigma square
equals lambda max of expectation x
squared and this is our matrix extension
of detail bound for a scalar Rademacher
series everything is exactly the same
except for the dimensional factor which
is necessary in some cases so there are
examples where that dimensional factor
really should be present on the tail
bound now what this tells you is that
the maximum eigenvalue you don't get any
information about it up until a certain
level and then you see that the tail
decays so and that level is lambda max
of expectation x squared to the one-half
that's not right if I'll draw this on
another board
so the impact the content of this result
is that if you want to plot the
probability that lambda max of this
Rademacher series exceeds T is a
function of T the bound is vacuous up
into a certain point and then it drops
off exponentially so the point where the
bound starts becoming informative is
root 2 Sigma squared log D and then
after that the scale for the deviations
is Sigma
now what if D were equal to 1 we are in
the scalar setting well this would be
exactly the result we got the first time
for scalars so we didn't lose anything
but again in the matrix setting we
really do have to eat the dimensional
factor for some examples unfortunately
this method can't tell you which ones
any questions about this result
yeah that seems to be what happens so
examples where you need this diagonal
matrices you'll actually see this kind
of behavior it comes from the central
limit theorem in that case this comes up
for certain kinds of sampling problems
it comes up if you apply this to like a
Tirpitz matrix with random plus minus
ones on the first and last row its
maximum eigen value has a log in it so
there are lots and lots of cases where
somehow you really do have to pay for
the logarithm it's not just trivial
but there are other cases where the law
just doesn't belong and this method
won't tell you that this pounder Sharpe
you can actually find examples of
saturate it where like this really is
the right estimate so so in spite of the
fact that you feel like this was a
really bad mistake wasn't so bad and by
the way um this really is the right
scale for these series so it's not hard
to check that that Sigma squared is less
than or equal to the expectation of x
squared is always so this bound tells
you that this bound is the upper bound
here okay the lower bound follows from
Jensen's inequality okay so the gap
really is just the logarithm you really
are not going to be able to escape from
that Sigma squared no matter what you do
so this really is identifying the sort
of most significant component of the
behavior yeah for diagonal matrices you
can on basically make gaussians on the
diagonal and you'll see a logarithm
because of the central limit zeroes did
you get the maximum of deal yep yep it's
like a union bow
no no no the log is always operator
monitor this is scaler result or not a
scaler result it's a deterministic
result so it holds for any positive
matrix of which the exponential is one
yes it is you can replace the D by
something that's called the intrinsic
dimension so you can replace D by
something that looks like the trace of
the expectation squared divided by the
norm of the expectation of the square
this is never bigger than d sometimes
it's a lot smaller but it doesn't really
solve the problem of getting rid of the
dimensional dependence so here not on
this result yes so I can actually good
this is a good place to describe the
difference so there's one other
technical point that I'd like to include
before we wrap up this time so what's
the difference between the Sol's about a
winter stuff and what we're doing here
so
okay so the bound that we got here has
Sigma squared equal to the sum of the
expectations of the terms epsilon K a K
squared which is of course just sum of a
K squared and norm okay
so this is what we got alls feta and
winter have this bound okay so they have
the same estimate except Sigma squared
is replaced by this quantity so you've
drawn the sum outside of the norm and so
you can see there's a huge difference
between these in general it can be as
much as the dimension of the matrix so
when these guys commute with each other
not a big deal
when they don't commute you can really
lose a lot so somehow a measure of how
similar the a K are with each other I
think that's right yes
that'll be useful
did him Olivera did not use the golden
Thompson equality and a really
insightful way as I mean as did also in
winter for that matter it's just that
somehow if you want this the full
strength of this bound that seems like
you really need to mimic the cumulant
generating functional argument from the
scalar case now one other one other
point here so was there anything really
special about that accumulating cumulant
generating function bound we proved
where we said oh what's the moment
generating function of a Rademacher
times a fixed matrix well we found a
bound for that but you can prove all
sorts of other cgf bounds exactly the
same way and you can get things like
tearing off in equality you should
improve the Bernstein and equality this
way you knew all sorts of other stuff by
mimicking this argument this is just the
simplest example okay there's one more
thing I want to tell you before we wrap
up for this hour and that's what you do
with rectangular matrices it seems like
that's a different problem but it's not
so will define a map H that takes a
matrix a general matrix B to the
following somewhat larger matrix okay
now this is obviously hermitian the
maximum eigenvalue of this guy is equal
to the spectral norm of B so you have to
check this and if V is d 1 by D 2 then
this is D 1 plus D 2 squared okay now if
you want to study Rademacher series with
rectangular matrices you just stick this
map in
so here's how this works
so if B 1 up to be n R D 1 by D 2
matrices and you're interested in a
Rademacher series composed of these
matrices the probability that the
spectral norm of Z exceeds T is equal to
the probability that the maximum eigen
value of H of Z exceeds T and so we know
that this is less than the dimension of
that matrix D 1 plus d 2 times the
expectation of the exponential minus T
squared over 2 Sigma squared where now
Sigma squared is the expectation of H of
Z squared ok well what's that huh turns
out that if you square this matrix you
get BB star in the upper left flock and
B star B in the lower right block and
the norm of this matrix is the maximum
of these two norms so this gives you the
expectation of Z Z star up here the
expectation of Z star Z down here and in
conclusion this is the expectation of
loops the expectation of Z Z star in
norm max with the expectation of Z star
Z in norm which is exactly the variance
we saw in the Bernstein inequality
mm-hmm no because of the expectation
they can average two very different
things
okay and so even though it seems like
the rectangular case might be somewhat
different it's really a formal
consequence of the square case of the
symmetric case and so you can prove all
of these nice results for maximum eigen
values and then get results for
rectangular matrices for free so a very
slick idea from operator theory all
right any last questions before we take
another break yes well it's the same
variance is enough yeah so what would
you need to do to convert this argument
into a Bernstein inequality so where was
the difference this is the assumptions
on the summons right so we used the fact
that the some ants were Rademacher is x
matrices to prove a cgf bound if you had
some general random matrix that were
zero mean and bounded you'd have to use
a different argument to get a different
bound than the CDF but you plug that in
you crank through the argument it's just
like the scalar case you wind up with a
Bernstein inequality instead yeah it
comes from having a different bound than
the continual generating function the
log of the moment generating function
that's it
I mean and then when you optimize over
that parameter theta it just gives you
that well if you're clever it gives you
that form for the the tail anything else
so let me suggest we think of shorter
break this time but actually like the
seven half go to the bathroom give your
favorite beverage takes a big breath sky
thing so we all lose people on the
Taylor today to attend push-ups and
we'll give Jeff Joel is last 30 minutes
solid four moments big moments